don't you let him get away  look  you need me you know that you know  leaving me about your choice  on the ground now  [Music]  right now we got no video so just my  testimony  kind of complicates things  i'm here to update your security camera  you're in the wrong place we got frank  richards used to be the police captain i  forgot to mention my daughter's coming  in  feels good to be back you really are a  bad country girl  look at missa you be clever out yeah  where the hell is he  at call your dad  chloe are you okay i'm just at the cabin  and i wanted to make sure that you're  still coming  why do you need to get to my dad  fix what's broke  what made a crucial mistake i'm gonna do  what i do best  where are you going  i'm ready for whatever's coming my way  [Music]  send back up  [Music]  nothing personal pal he's just in the  wrong place at the wrong time  [Music]  you